well good
afternoon good to see you all here I've
never um I've never been here before and
it's been a bit of a revelation what the
middle west looks like if you go just a
little further east and a little further
north from
Kansas where I grew up you guys have
more trees you got more
water um
I am retired I've been retired for years
except evidently I don't know how to do
a very good job of that was talking to
my sister and the driver uh on the
way here
today uh she's telling me that now she's
retired I said you'll love it I'm
retired I've been retired forever she
said you're not
retired they all think I I'm still
working I told her this is not
work this is
fun okay where are we I got my clicker
by the way before before we begin so I
don't forget and then you'll come up
later and say who was that old guy in
the first slide that's me in Disguise I
was chief of Disguise at CIA that's
where I ended up certainly isn't where I
began I was just sitting with Addison
and she said well where did you begin
how did you how did you join the
CIA um I'll make it very very fast I was
in Europe my best friend back in Kansas
got married in Germany I was in her
wedding they went on a honeymoon I
decided not to go back to Witchita
Kansas um I got a job I called all these
banks in Frankfurt Germany uh the Third
Bank I
called they asked me four questions and
they hired me on the phone you want to
know the questions they said oh you're
looking for a job do you speak German I
said no I said have you ever worked in a
bank before I said no what was the next
question question it was a note did I
have a work permit which was required in
Germany no they said well come on down
and talk to us and they hired
me that's what started everything and
oddly I'm I'm a board member at the
International Spy Museum back in
Washington DC if any of you get there go
see it it's it's just it's really
cool but I spoke to a group there two
weeks ago and guess what it was JP
Morgan Chase Manhattan bank and I got to
thank them all these years later for
starting uh me on my career anyway uh I
met some Young Americans there we um we
had a really wonderful time going to
Switzerland going to France I married
one of them a year and a half later he
told me three days before the wedding
that he wasn't really a civilian working
with the military that he worked for the
CIA and I was like I was 21 and I was
like that's okay yeah okay
he worked for the CIA and they hired me
as a secretary and I was a secretary for
a while uh I was a very good secretary I
ended up being the secretary for the
director of the office and I was I was
bored so I told my boss I I was going to
go to work to the at the Smithsonian I
was going to talk to them and he said no
no no he said we'll give you some photo
lessons and off we went so I have to
tell you where I worked at the CIA where
I was for those 27 years starting as a
contract wife ending up as the chief of
Disguise which is a really very cool job
um we were the queue to CIA just like in
the James Bond movies we were composed
of chemists mechanical engineers
electrical engineers physicists
specialists in Optics specialists in in
in ink state-of-the-art Technologies we
were inventing them if the if the thing
that our officer needed for his
operation didn't exist yet we would
invent it for him it was a really
exciting place to work um and I stayed
there my entire career oddly is it odd
today everyone at CIA stayed there
people didn't just pop in and pop out so
today when I meet someone that says I
just met someone she said I was there
for 6 years and I meet her and I'm
looking at her thinking what went wrong
you're supposed to be there for your
career um I still don't know what went
wrong it's
okay my husband Tony Mendes by the way
he of Argo Fame did anybody see
Argo CIA loved Argo they did it's the
only good movie that's ever been made
about them but just for for
clarification my husband uh was out in
Denver Colorado when he saw an ad in the
um in the Denver Post wanted to work
overseas for the US Navy an artist to
work overseas for the US Navy so he
applied and he ended up in Washington DC
um showing him putting his his work
product out uh so they could judge his
uh skills and they hired him and he had
been thinking the whole time what in the
world do they want with an artist what's
an artist going to do at the
CIA well they don't like to say that
they're looking for a counterfeit or
forger
cuz but that's what they hired him for
to do counterfeiting and forgeries
because it's a necessary piece of the
work Tony was really good at it he was
so good at it that we we bumped into it
a couple of times uh once I remember we
were we were at the airport we were
going to France France we had our young
son with us we were in the Air France
line we get to the front the Frenchman
across the counter was not a likable
Frenchman he was an arrogant Frenchman
he looked at you like I don't know we
didn't like him a lot maybe he felt that
so he picked up Tony's passport and he
held it like it was dirty and he said
she is
expired she is expired his passport my
husband the head of all documents for
CIA is at dullas airport with his
passport and it's expired and I'm over
I'm over in the corner with a pile of
luggage and my son I'm trapped I can't
do a thing which is hard for me and he
said okay he said five minutes in the
men's room I can fix
this and I I the voice of reason I said
but you know now it would be a
felony so we went down to K Street we
got him a new passport overnight and off
we went to France uh he also I'm going
Way Off Script here he also told me he
was going to give a course at the uh
International Spy Museum on forgeries on
counterfeiting and I said why would you
do that you're going to teach people how
to he said absolutely he said I see it
like a Julia Child there's a mirror
above me
I'm at a desk they can all you know they
can see what I'm doing and I'll show
them how it works and I said you know I
I just thought it was the stupidest
thing he taught a room full of people to
forge Vladimir Putin's
signature and to pass the course you had
to bring it up show it to him he'd
initial it and he'd say go make good
trouble good go make Mischief go do
something fun with
that okay we're going to go back back to
the
script we were we were uh we were the
gadget people at CIA if you needed to
bug a place if you needed an audio bug
if you needed a counterfeit document if
you needed let me think of some other
things well if you needed disguises you
would come and see me if you needed a
concealed camera early in my career you
would come and see me no matter what it
was you were thinking about if you
needed it for your operation you'd swing
by our office and our Engineers that
half of us that invented and built
machinery and things they would help you
my half would go overseas with you we'd
go with you because unlike those silly
James Bond movies we didn't trust James
worth a
nickel he would lose it he would break
it he would forget how it worked he'd
leave it on the Metro we went with our
$2 million piece of equipment and make
sure made sure that it worked
and that he gave it back to us when it
was all over so that was half of the fun
and I I used to tell Tony don't tell
them it's fun because it doesn't sound
serious it was fun doing some of this
work the work was overseas all the work
was overseas never forget we were
working overseas collecting the
information on the plans and intentions
of this country's enemies full stop
that's the job what are they going to do
we had satellite programs up there they
could tell us the status quo at any
given
moment um we had a lot of ways that we
could monitor what was happening right
now we knew that we wanted to know what
are they going to do next what are they
planning that's what we were out there
looking for we were looking for people
who had access to that information and
trying to figure out how to get close
enough to those people how to befriend
them how to help them whatever you had
to
do to get them to tell you what you
needed to know so if you could only
imagine some foreign person sidles up to
you in a bar somewhere and says listen I
know you work over here and I'd really
really love to have your help about this
or that and would ask you to betray your
country there's not a person in this
room that would go along with that so we
never did it that way but we had to get
the information somehow from these
people whether they realized or not that
we were
collecting here we go with the technical
stuff let's see if it
works this was one of my programs this
was called a tropel um the tropel pin
and inside the pin is a camera in the in
the upper leftand corner that smallest
cylinder is the camera and the camera
inside of the cylinder is a cartridge
like the uh old Kodak yellow film
cartridge but this is so much smaller
and inside the cartridge is the tiniest
piece of film you ever saw it's about
that long you could take a hundred
pictures with that camera that camera
was one of the most lethal weapons we
had during the Cold
War we didn't give just anybody that
camera but if we had an agent who had
access to the tippy top of wherever it
was whatever it was we were looking for
give him the camera so he could be
standing at Putin's desk making notes
Putin's talking Putin turns his heads
talking to someone else our guy can just
flip the pen silently with one finger
take a picture Putin turns back flip the
camera make another note put the pen in
your pocket and go to lunch with him we
collected so much intelligence with this
one tool
but it was kind of
heart-stopping to develop the film every
time I developed that film I thought you
know someone in the world risk their
life to take the these images I cannot I
cannot screw this up every time you did
it it was like you were starting over
you can't screw it up don't mess up the
film this is the kgb's kind of answer to
that this is a KGB coat has six buttons
and in one of the buttons the one there
in the middle is a camera and what he's
holding in his hand is the actuator for
that camera it would normally be in his
pocket you wouldn't know the camera was
there you wouldn't know the actuator was
there and he'd walk down the street
toward you he'd be taking your picture
the whole time he's walking toward you
KGB was um trying to do the same thing
we were just from the flip side of
things um this is the kind of thing we
did this is a this is a one-time pad if
you've ever heard of an enigma machine
during World War II the the German
Enigma machine was based on a one-time
pad it was an encrypted device that was
unbreakable absolutely unbreakable and
at the Spy Museum up on the wall they
have posted a number it's one number of
the the possible number of settings for
the Enigma machine and you can't even
say it in words you have to see this
number you can't there are no words for
it and that was true true it was
unbreakable as long as the German only
used the onetime pad one
time so during World War II I don't know
if you knew this but the poles found a
crack in that system and a German used
the One Time Pad twice and that's all it
took the Polish intelligence service
broke the Enigma code during the second
world war and gave the allies of course
the result and so we were able to see
the German traffic the submarine traffic
the traffic on the ground Winston
Churchill knew where they were going to
bomb he knew who was in danger he knew
which cathedral in in in England was
going to be bombed next but they
couldn't they couldn't react to it they
couldn't say get out of the way
something bad is coming tomorrow poor
Winston Churchill on top of everything
else had to sit on this information for
the duration of the war we use the
onetime pads it's concealed in a fake
it's not a fake Walnut it's just an
empty Walnut we used onetime pads for a
lot of the small devices that we would
issue to our agents where we couldn't
meet with them face to face maybe it was
too dangerous so they could communicate
with us um
electronically uh this is musco this was
a a device where we could tell if the
Russians were following us it was a
receiver it's kind of like what the uh
Secret Service uses with president today
but instead of having that cable or like
a water hose coming out of your ear
where everybody knows Secret Service
Secret Service we had something called a
phac it's made by by the Swiss it's a
little tiny thing it's inside of that
Circle put the phac in your
ear